imam husain was killed in the Battle of
Karbala in what is now Iraq 1300 years
ago Shia Muslims commemorate his death
every year on the 10th day of the
Islamic calendars first month the influx
of visitors is putting a huge strain on
Iraq's infrastructure and services local
companies in the government are
investing heavily to try and improve
this situation as Charles Stratford
reports that being helped by the
country's biggest foreign investor Iran
every year millions of Shia Muslims from
around the world come to Karbala for
Ashura time to pray and mourn the death
of the Prophet Muhammad's grandson
hussein abu ali the feeling is is beyond
words you know you cannot explain some
people wear costumes depicting hussein
and his followers people queue for free
food at kitchens set up by volunteers a
lot of the writing on signs is in farsi
because many of the visitors are from
iran the Iraqi government dropped visa
fees for Iranians in April many of the
young and old whipped themselves in
remembrance of what they described as
the martyrdom Hussein sure is perhaps
most associated with the practice of
self-flagellation but that's just one of
the many ways
and many of the Shia Muslims that come
here every year commemorates a security
here is improved in recent years so was
the amount of investment and this one
country that's investing much some more
than others here and that Iran hotels
residential buildings and office blocks
are rising above the city's skyline the
giant black flag is perhaps a reminder
of the importance of religion and
tradition here no matter the future
development plans Iran is by far the
biggest investor here Iraq she is a huge
border with Iran and a common religion
Iran had a vital role in fighting ISIL
in Iraq so it's benefitting politically
and economically in Iraq now but we hope
that eventually the Iraqi companies can
be stronger than the foreign ones
Iran is pouring money into religious
tourism around the holy sites in Karbala
but Iraq is a major US ally some US
officials have complained to their Iraqi
counterparts that Iran is investing here
to try and lessen the effects of
sanctions over its nuclear program the
Iraqi and the Iranian government's
recently signed agreements focusing on
infrastructure development and hope to
build a direct rail link between the two
countries trade between Iran and Iraq is
worth around 12 billion dollars a year
Iraqi religious leaders say donations
and investment is flooding in from
around the world but they don't deny
that Iran is the biggest foreign player
here how hard was an odds in the next
four years will expand the area up to 20
times the size it is now because the
numbers of people visiting increases
every year we're also expanding projects
offering services such as hospitals and
schools to try to supplement government
efforts which don't meet the people's
needs
but no matter who supplies the money to
develop this holy city for now the focus
is on mourning and prayer chants
trafford al jazeera Karbala